PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, welcome.
My name is Paul Saxman, and
welcome to the premiere
episode of The Mobile
Experience.
In this series, we'll be
covering UI guidelines and
design principles for building
location-based
applications with maps.
In this episode in particular,
we'll be covering how to
implement a interface for
browsing a list of places
using a scrollable view
interface, or
ViewPager in Android.
In iOS, the equivalent would
be a UIScrollView.
Using pagination or paging.
To demo, this technique, we're
going to actually build an
application over a series
of episodes.
We're calling this application
the Walkway app.
The principle it's designed on
are based on what we presented
in Google I/O--
that was a walker app--
in the show called Making
Location Meaningful with the
Google Maps APIs.
This application covers
a number of use cases.
The primary use case is
displaying a view, or showing
a route for exploring
a location.
The user can view a list of
places along this route.
They can choose which places
they want to maybe stop by or
maybe not stop by.
They can also tweak the types
of places they want to see.
So if they want to stop by cafes
or museums, they can put
that in there.
Or maybe they don't want to
stop by these places.
They'd rather stop by the bar.
So basically, they establish a
route and also establish a
series of places they
want to stop by.
Another thing that we might add
to this application in the
future is maybe a
social aspect.
We could do something like
Ways for Walking.
It might be kind of fun.
But that would definitely
be in a much
further future episode.
So with that, why don't we jump
into a quick demo of the
application the way
it is right now.
You can see here, the
application takes some
inspiration from the Google
Maps Mobile application.
And that's actually
on purpose.
They put a lot of effort into
building a nice user interface
that is single-handed
exploration.
You can see on the bottom here,
we have a ViewPager.
The ViewPager is this is a
white box on the bottom.
And right now, it says
the ferry building.
And if you see, if I take this
ViewPager and I slide across,
you see a new place in the
map, and you also see new
place in the ViewPager.
So right now it's saying
exploratorium.
So this ViewPager, the point of
this is it allows the user
to navigate through a list of
places very rapidly just using
their thumb.
Like I said, this is a
single-handed interface, which
is very nice for if you're
carrying a bag, you're walking
along carrying your coffee or
other beverage, and you just
want to quickly browse
through this list of
places on the map.
Another thing you'll notice
about this interface as well
is that we have a
nice big map.
The purpose of the big map is to
allow the user really easy
navigation with their thumb
on the map as well.
Smaller map's actually a little
harder to get to more
accurate positioning.
And also, the larger map lets
us zoom out to a high enough
level so that we can see of
the places at one time.
So this is just a pre-canned
list of places that I put in
the application.
But future episodes will maybe
integrate with the Places API
to do a dynamic list.
And allow the user, like I said,
to add and remove their
own places.
Another thing you'll notice is
when I'm sliding the ViewPager
is that there's only one
marker highlighted on
the map at a time.
So the highlighted marker
corresponds to what's
displayed in the ViewPager.
And the interesting thing about
this is this eliminates
the need for using
info windows.
So the bad thing about info
windows is if the map is
scrolled off to the side and
the marker is no longer
displayed, you no longer
see the last
thing that you selected.
But using the ViewPager, you
actually still see the place
in the bottom of the screen.
I can get back to the map.
So as you see, as I'm scrolling
through the list of
places in the ViewPager,
one markers
highlighted at any one time.
The other thing that I did here
is these dot markers--
or measle markers,
of you may--
these are also touchable
or clickable.
If I click on one of these, it
takes focus, and ViewPager
updates its position.
So the nice thing about this
is the user can actually
navigate entirely on the map.
They don't actually have to
use the ViewPager if they
don't want to.
So they can explore the area
spatially using the map
instead of exploring the places
using the ViewPager.
Another thing that's implemented
here is if the
user clicks on the highlighted
marker.
You see you get this nice
zoom-in effect.
This is the detail mode.
You get the same effect if you
touch or just click the
ViewPager for the highlighted
place.
It zooms in and shows
detailed view.
In a future episode, what we
can do is maybe add more
detailed information
about the place.
For example, on the Google Maps
Mobile application, what
that does is when you click on
the place, it pulls up a
drawer where you can actually
see more information.
We're not going to try to
implement everything that the
Google Maps Mobile
application does.
But where it makes sense in
this application, we may
integrate those designs.
What I did with the
back button is it
has two states now.
One, if we're zoomed in in a
detailed mode, you see here if
I click the Back button, it's
going to zoom back out to the
full map mode.
So essentially, the first mode
is resetting the map.
The second mode is actually
going to reset the ViewPager
so the user can get back
to the original
location on the list.
Because remember, this
is a walking path.
So we're going from the ferry
building to the very last
place, which is Yerba
Buena Gardens.
So at some point, the user may
want to actually get back to
the very first place.
And using the back button's a
very nice way to do that.
If I were building this
application in iOS, which
doesn't have a Back button, you
probably want to put some
kind of UI control maybe in the
title bar or in the menu
bar, or an overlay over the map
that allows the user to
actually reset their
map state.
So with that, I'm going to start
jumping into a little
bit of code to show
you how this is
implemented in Android.
This part'll get a little bit
boring for you iOS developers.
But we'll potentially implement
the same interface
in iOS in a future episode
and share that
code with you as well.
So if we take a look at the code
now for this application
in Android, you can see here
that this is the layout file
for the main interface.
So we only have one
interface here.
If you remember the application,
I've removed
everything--
all the superfluous
UI controls,
like the action bar--
for the time being.
So all we have is the map and
the ViewPager at the bottom.
You see this frame layout.
This just allows me to do
overlays on top of the map.
There's just a very
subtle shadow
effect over the ViewPager.
And the bottom here is where
you actually see
the ViewPager itself.
It's very simple to implement.
It's part of the Support
Library, which means it's
supported across a number of
different Android releases.
And essentially, all you need
is a position for it and the
layout width and height.
I've actually specified
the height.
I fixed the height to 85 DPI,
which was a nice height for
thumb swiping.
When you take a back to the
interface on the phone, it was
a little bit sparse.
There was just a little
bit of text in there.
Eventually, we can add more
information to that ViewPager,
similar to how we would
potentially use an info window.
So if we go back, actually, to
the code itself, instantiating
the ViewPager.
I'm just going to pull
it out of the layout.
Give it a PagerAdapter.
And I'll discuss the
PagerAdapter in a little bit.
The PagerAdapter is how you
get the data and the views
instantiated for
the ViewPager.
And here, I implemented an
OnPageChangeListener.
So this is how I'm capturing
these events as the user's
swiping from left to right.
And I'm using this event to
change the focused marker.
So I'm taking the previously
focused marker, I'm shrinking
it down to a dot marker.
And the inverse, taking the
new highlighted marker and
blowing it up.
Let's take a look at
the PagerAdapter.
So there's several different
versions of this.
There's the PagerAdapter,
which is the base class.
And then there's two concrete
implementations of this.
There's the FragmentPagerAdapter
and the
FragmentStatePagerAdapter.
The latter two require you
to instantiate fragments.
These are actually for the pages
in the view, ViewPager.
I chose to use just a
PagerAdapter to instantiate
views, not fragments, just
because it's a lot simpler for
this use case.
Future episodes, though, I'd
probably want to think about
migrating to the
FragmentStateAdapter and
actually making these pages
first-class citizens or
reusable components.
Right now, they're just baked
into the application.
But this is a very simple, quick
and easy way to get up
and running with these pages.
As you can see, in the
application right now, it's
just essentially the
name of the place.
Here, I'm actually attaching an
OnClickListener to the View.
That's how I'm allowing the user
to actually zoom in to
get the detailed view.
A click event on the view, in
the ViewPager, allows us to
zoom in to that particular
place on the map.
So coordinating between the
map and the ViewPager.
The way I'm actually doing all
this coordination in this code
between the ViewPager and the
map is using indices.
Because the ViewPager, when
you get events on the
ViewPager, it's by position,
what page
you're on in the ViewPager.
I use that position to go back
to my collection of places or
markers to actually update
them in the map.
And that's this code
following below.
The next thing that we'll
probably want to look at is
the marker itself.
So the markers are
fairly simple.
All I did here, though, is I
added OnClickListener or
onMarkerClick click
to the map.
That allows me to
do two things.
If the user clicks the currently
highlighted marker,
you get the zoom-in feature,
or the detail view.
If it's not the currently
selected one, then we go
through that process
of highlighting it
and updating it.
So essentially, just telling
the ViewPager
to update its item.
Then the ViewPager gets that
event and does its work to
change which marker
is highlighted.
So that's pretty much
it for the code.
There's a few things that I'll
probably want to add to this.
Let's take a look at the
application one more time.
So a few things.
I ran a little mini
usability study.
I took this application
and gave it
to a few of my friends.
I said, play around with it.
Tell me what you think.
And they gave me, actually,
some really good feedback.
A few people isn't an
extensive study.
But it's always good when you
have somebody else besides
yourself, or somebody that you
aren't working really closely
with on an application to
take a look and tell
you what they think.
So one bit of feedback that I
got is it's not always obvious
that the ViewPager
is an interactive
component on this interface.
When you first start the
application, you just see
whatever the default was here.
This ferry building.
It's not necessarily apparent
that you can actually swipe
left and right on ViewPager.
So one trick that we might think
about implementing here
to actually make it apparent
to the user that it is
interactive is on start up, you
can give it a little bit
of a wiggle.
So have the ViewPager maybe
move left and right, or
actually iterate through
a few items to show
the user how it works.
You could do this only the first
couple of times on start
up, and then not
do it anymore.
And actually, I've seen that
implementation on another
application.
It was the Open Table
application that
has a similar interface.
They do that on start up.
Another thing that you could do
is put in angle brackets on
the right- or left-hand
side of the ViewPager.
That generally indicates that
there's more information, give
the user some kind of clue
that they can find more
information to the
left or right.
So it'd be a nice interface
thing to add to this
application.
Pager looping.
So another bit of feedback that
I got is that when you to
the beginning or end of this
list of places, it can be a
little bit frustrating when
you can't continue on.
You might want to, instead of
stopping at the last page or
the last marker, actually just
flip over and start at the
beginning again.
I don't know if that's
necessarily easy to implement
with the ViewPager.
I think it might be more easy
if you had just a scrollable
view of some sort.
But one thing we could do is
potentially just, when the
user gets to the end,
automatically take it back to
the beginning.
You could add a number of
repeated places, repeated
views to the ViewPager.
So as the user keep scrolling
on there,
you're getting new views.
But essentially, these are
views of the same data.
A number of different
things we could do.
But yeah, definitely it seems
like a little bit of a
frustrating thing, to get to the
end of this list and not
be able to start over.
And one last thing.
So as you can see, what's
happening here is, as I'm
scrolling through this list of
places in the ViewPager, I'm
actually re-centering the map.
So the highlighted markers
in the center of the map.
Which is a very nice design,
because you always have what's
important in the middle.
However, we wouldn't always have
to reposition the map if
the newly highlighted marker
is already near the center.
We could just highlight
that marker as the
user scrolls through.
And that allows, if the user has
repositioned the map, if
they're looking at a
neighborhood that's more
relevant, or an area of the map
that's more relevant to
them, and they scroll to a new
marker that's on that place on
the map already, we're
not actually
re-centering the map for them.
I actually played around
with that a little bit.
It wasn't too easy to do
off the top of my head.
Just because what you have to
do is you can tell which
markers are on the
current map.
But you can't tell how
much padding is
around those markers.
So for example, if one of these
markers was off to the
edge, I could tell if
it was on the map.
But I can't tell, if I inflate
the marker or make the marker
bigger, if the markers is
visible on the map.
So there's a few things that I
might try to play around with
that for a future episode.
But this is how we're going to
keep it for the time being.
We don't think zoom is
necessarily a bad thing.
But we always want to make
this a little bit better.
There's a few things that
I was going to--
a few things that are
interesting to mention about
this interface as well.
That I think we'll also work on
or potentially talk about
in a future episode.
You can see that I took
the action bar out.
That's only just because I don't
have any other in-app
navigation, presently,
in this application.
If I didn't want to have other
activities, I'd definitely
want to have an action bar.
Otherwise, I'd also consider
putting in a navigation bar in
a future episode.
For example, if I want to
browse, or have other commands
that you could do.
Let's say if you want to add or
remove places from the list
of places on the map, or redo
your search, a navigation bar
would be nice.
And the way to get to the
Navigation bar would be via
the Action bar.
Or actually, a drawer handle.
But we'll play around with
that in future episodes.
The other thing that's
interesting with this
interface, you can actually see
in the code, is these dot
markers are actually
shape drawables.
So they're simple enough as
vector graphics, or vector
shapes, that I can define them
as an XML shape drawable.
They're just a circle with
a gradient inside.
That allows me to actually scale
them to any size that I
want, dynamically,
if I want to.
And also, if I do want to change
the color of the style
of these markers, I don't have
to go back to my drawing tool
and regenerate raster
images for that.
I could just go in and tweak
the color settings.
I thought about actually doing
it even more dynamically.
So for example, with the
highlighted marker.
These are the default markers
they come with the maps SDK.
You specify the hue that
you want to use.
You take that hue and apply it
to the marker gradient so that
you use the hue of the main
marker to define the color of
the markers, but not
too much work.
So having the shape drawable,
though, is actually a nice
thing to do.
Thanks for joining me.
I hope you found this
episode helpful.
The code that I demoed
today is actually all
available on GitHub.
The link is below.
We're going to continue to build
this application out in
future episodes.
So if you have any feedback,
you can provide either on
GitHub, in the GitHub
repository, or
on our Google+ page.
We're happy to get all your
feedback and potentially
implement those ideas
in future shows.
So thanks again.